[Musique]
bonsoir Laure Manin bonsoir Audrey et on
va reparler avec vous de l'Ukraine de ce
chantage au gaz Vladimir Poutine exige à
nouveau que le gaz russe lui soit payé
en rouble vous voyez le président russe
qui veut qui ne veut plus qui reveut qui
hésite et qui je dis après midi avec
expliqué que cette exigence d'être payée
en rouble qu'il avait formulé à la
semaine précédente ne s'appliquait pas
je cite à ses partenaires européens
nouveau revirement ce jeudi si c'est
client ne se plient pas à sa volonté le
maître du Kremlin menace de fermer les
robinets les précisions d'être Viégeois
Manissa
dès ce vendredi il faudra bel et bien du
rouble au pays de l'Union européenne
pour acheter du gaz russe en cas de
refus Vladimir Poutine a prévenu les
contrats d'approvisionnement au gaz
seront suspendus une mesure adopter en
représailles aux sanctions économiques
des Occidentaux après l'invasion de
l'Ukraine pour acheter du gaz naturel
russe il doit ouvrir des comptes en
rouble dans les banques russes et c'est
avec ses comptes qu'ils pourront payer
le gaz ça commencera à partir de demain
le 1er avril hier pourtant Vladimir
Poutine assurait que l'Europe pouvait
continuer à payer le gaz russe en euros
et non en rouble contrairement à ce
qu'il avait annoncé la semaine
précédente Moscou espère ainsi soutenir
le cours de sa monnaie nationale qui a
perdu un tiers de sa valeur depuis la
mise en place des sanctions
le G7 et l'Union européenne ont
catégoriquement refusé l'Allemagne
estime avoir le droit de refuser cette
mesure qui faut livraison de gaz et aux
autres livraisons il stipule que les
paiements sont effectués en euros
parfois en dollars les généralement en
euros et j'ai clairement indiqué au
président russe qui en serait ainsi je
me présente
de l'économie Bruno Le Maire a invité la
Russie à honorer dans son intégralité
les contrats tel qu'ils ont été signés
ce dossier est crucial pour les pays
occidentaux en particulier pour l'Union
européenne dépendante à 40% de la Russie
pour ses importations de gaz
le gaz n'est pas la seule denrée au cœur
de ce bras de fer entre les Occidentaux
et la Russie le pétrole aussi pourrait
venir à manquer oui le pétrole russe
représente entre 25 et 30% des
importations européennes là encore si la
Russie ferme les robinets les Européens
vont se trouver fort des pourvu leur
noir c'est d'ailleurs très fortement
apprécié ces dernières semaines en
particulier depuis l'invasion de
l'Ukraine on voit ce pic à 129 dollars
qui remontent à début mars juste
quelques jours après l'invasion de
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui c'est stabilisé
autour de 108 dollars mais vous le voyez
en décembre au moment du début de la
reprise de la Poste pandémie le baril
s'évaluait autour de 70 dollars
seulement cette hausse des prix répond
bien sûr à la question à la loi de
l'offre et de la demande moins de
pétrole pour une demande qui ne change
pas ça fait mécaniquement monter les
prix quels sont les moyens de soulager
la pression sur les prix du pétrole et
bien aux États-Unis Joe Biden s'est
prononcé tout à l'heure il va piocher un
million de barils quotidiens
supplémentaires dans les réserves
stratégiques du pays les Etats-Unis
rappelons-le sont tout de même le
premier producteur de pétrole au monde
alors cette ce recours réserves
stratégique ça va principalement
soulager les ménages américains ça ne
devrait pas infléchir considérablement
les prix internationaux précédent donc
de soulager cette pression en augmentant
leur nombre de barils de pétrole produit
chaque jour les pays producteurs de
l'OPE plus ont expliqué de leur côté
qu'il ne comptait pas tellement ouvrir
beaucoup plus les vans je vous propose
de les écouter
aujourd'hui tout le monde dit augmenter
votre production apporter plus de
ressources mais si vous allez voir les
institutions financières elles sont un
peu hésitantes et elles hésitent encore
à financer de nombreux projets
pétroliers et gaziers dans le monde en
gros on nous dit on a besoin que vous
augmentiez la production pour quelques
années seulement et après cela merci
beaucoup comme si c'était un robinet que
vous ouvriez et que vous pouviez fermer
toutes ces informations ça se traduit
comment sur les marchés ah bien c'est du
rouge partout Wall Street finissent ce
dernier jour du premier trimestre dans
le rouge premier trimestre négatif
depuis le début 2020 et le commencement
de la pandémie aux États-Unis
l'incertitude autour de la guerre en
Ukraine l'inflation record en
particulier aux États-Unis et puis une
croissance qui est relative notamment ce
bilan la volonté la volatilité des prix
de l'énergie pèse également sur les
actions le dos est de 1,56% moins 1 56
également pour le SNP 500 - 1 54 pour le
Nasdaq c'est donc franchement rouge
premier trimestre négatif également de
ce côté de l'Atlantique l'Europe avec
les principales bourses européennes en
être recul aussi toujours autour de
cette incertitude sur la guerre en
Ukraine et puis de l'inflation qui
rentre des investisseurs frileux - 1,21
pour le cas à Paris - 1 31 pour le Dax à
Francfort Londres sans sort un peu mieux
avec un fossil qui recule seulement de
0,83 merci beaucoup Laure Manin